la russie at elle demandé l'aide de la
chine dans sa guerre en ukraine oui
selon le new york times qui se fait
l'écho des déclarations de plusieurs
responsables américains confrontés à une
forte résistance en ukraine moscou
pourrait ainsi réclamer un soutien
militaire mais aussi économique à pékin
le kremlin ni fermement la chine
démentent aussi et parle de
désinformation
les etats unis ont récemment diffusé une
série de fausses nouvelles visant la
chine sur la question de l'ukraine avec
des intentions malveillantes la position
de la chine sur la question de l'ukraine
a été claire et cohérente claire et
cohérente pas si sûr pour de nombreux
spécialistes la chine tente de trouver
un équilibre entre son soutien affiché à
son allié et sa volonté de ne pas se
retrouver en opposition frontale avec
les pays occidentaux la chine n'approuve
pas la position russe son offensive en
ukraine mais elle ne la condamne pas
elle s'est abstenue par exemple à
plusieurs reprises à l'onu lors de
résolution qui condamne et justement
l'agression russe et la plupart du temps
les médias chinois reprennent des
éléments de langage de la russie il n'y
a pas de guerre il s'agit d'un conflit
d'une opération spéciale de tension donc
la chine c'est un allié de circonstance
de la russie elle veut le rester elle ne
lâchera pas la russie en rase campagne
mais elle ne veut pas non plus passer
pour un paria au vis-à-vis des
occidentaux elle ne veut pas s'infliger
des sanctions occidentales si son
soutien à la russie est trop fort
l'équilibré est précaire pour la chine
qui préfère garder ses distances en
refusant notamment de jouer les
médiateurs dans ce dossier
de son côté si washington hausse le ton
le président américain joe biden
n'entend pas pour le moment imposé de
sanctions à pékin